[Music]
Secretary of State solid field of the
United States of America
so are you like dating the Prime
Minister of Canada no no no it's weird I
know this great little place not too far
from here
Oh it's called a minibar and it's in my
room you wanna know hey I put up with my
fair share of world leaders to 369 Fidel
Castro once you thought his beard was
big so how does that work with you to
like date guys don't really want to date
women who are more powerful than them
that's a picture their dicks Tripler is
my favorite Batman Billa though so you
can ask why I'm still single
just breathe we're seconds in
the optics of you and Fred would destroy
your entire career it's pretty woman but
she's Richard Gere and you're Julia
Roberts got destiny on your side I feel
so scared I'm gonna try to conduct
myself in such a way that does not risk
global humiliation she bought me this
ship it's a traditional Swedish suit
don't you another [ __ ] sweetie dressed
like this I'm the Smurf down we're gonna
[ __ ] suit next time
right I need you to come work on that
speech with me right now I'm having too
bossy no no we'll do exactly what you
are imagining and then you turned me
around slapped me my husband took me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]